foreign
it is approved system where it allows
approver to convince our verifier that
some machine M Wrong song input X will
output one we're seeing two steps and
here the machine m is some determinist
or non-determined security machine
and will require the proof size to be
short on the verification time to be
much faster than this t
and we also require the following
completeness and soundness for
completeness we require if M of x equals
T1 then the only study generated proof
will always be accepted
and the for the soundness we require
that if M of X doesn't equals to 1
within two steps then any efficiently
generation proof should be always
rejected
so an important subclass of MP is called
a batch NP
and then in a snug for batch MP the
prover tries to convince the wirefire
that a batch of K statements are all
true NP statements
in a single message and we we require
the proof size of such a proof to grow
with one of the MP Witness
and uh so previously this subclass of NP
is known as the complete problem towards
building stock for p in the sense that
if you know how to build snacks for
patch MP then we can compile it
generically to obtain snark4p
the similar some similar notion of this
batch proof was also considered before
in the context of digital signatures and
the interactive proofs such as
multi-signatures or interactive batch
proofs
so previously we know how to build a
snacks for P or patch NP from standard
cryptographic assumption where we all
started cryptographic assumption
and we know how to build a snack for P
or patch NP from learning with battle
assumption
and recently the work by Waters and
contractors MP from by linear Max
and also there is a another work
contracted those snarks from if you
helmet assumption and the quadratic
residuality assumption
so the letter two Works they are
stronger so the Assumption they use are
stronger than the difficult assumption
on non-parent groups
so what is this DP home assumption so
the difficult summation is defined as
follows
so it's assumed that given two random
group elements G today and g2b it is
hard to distinguish this G to the ad
from a random group element
I know this assumption was firstly used
to achieve public key encryption
publicly cryptography for the first time
so in this work we study the following
question can we build a snarks for p and
the patch NP from decisional DP hormone
from the DP hormone assumption
so answering this question can help us
understand the power of different
assumption
so we have a DP home assumption and
other cryptographic assumptions
so it's interesting to understand for
the cryptographic functionalities that
can be achieved by latest assumption and
the binary assumption can we also
achieve the same functionality from the
DV hormone assumption
or is it is there a gap between DP Homer
summation and these other cryptographic
assumptions
so recent years such a gap between
becomes narrower and narrower
so in the context of multi-party
computation the work of boil at all
contracted the succinct secure
computation from this difficult
assumption
and in the context of advanced
encryption schemes the work by floating
on the guard contracted identification
identity based encryption from Deep
Health assumption
we constructed a non-interactive zero
knowledge proof systems from
sub-exponential hardiness of DP helmet
so in this work our focus is on snarks
so we try to understand whether such gap
between DP home assumption and other
cryptographic assumptions exist or not
in the context of snarks so can we build
the snarks from DP hormone assumption
and here is our results
we constructed the snarks for p and The
Bachelor and P from the sub-exponential
harness of DP helmet assumption
so there's some explanations in our work
is defined as follows we assume that
there exists a constant C such that for
any polynomial for any adversary letter
runs in some slightly super polynomial
time which is a laminate to the
uh all the Lambda to the order of local
Lambda to the cube time it can still not
distinguish a ddh2o and the random Tuple
with other one digit or more than some
sub-exponential amount so here in this
sub-exponential dth assumption we not
only require the advantage to be a
sub-exponential amount we also require
we also allow the distinguisher to run
in some slightly super polynomial attack
why are we choosing this particular log
log lambdaq or something yes uh you you
all see whatever so we will use some
complex similarities
so
in as a concurrent work the worker by
color at all they also contract the
snarks for all for uh
deterministical computation from
sub-exponential dth assumption
foreign
[Music]
is correlation intractable for our
relation class r
if for any relation or in this relation
class for any problem adversely given
the harsh key sample based on kitchen
algorithm it is hard to for this
adversary to find some input X such that
the input output pair of this hash
function under this pointer X satisfy
this relation
the so this is the definition of
correlation interactable hash so this
kind of hash function has found many
applications recently such as showing
the counting examples to zero knowledge
and it was also used to build
non-interactive zero knowledge proof
systems
and it was used to contract wi-fiable
delay functions
and it was also used to show the
complexity of a peacock hardness
for the harness automatically
and recently it was also used to build
error creating codes
so
so why we care about such a special hash
function
so we'll use this circulation in
charitable hash to instantiate the
financial Paradigm and then build the
snarks
so recall that to finish Sharma Paradigm
starting with some interactive protocol
where all the wire virus message are
uniform random strings
so here is an example for three round
interactive protocol where the two
percent of the first message X and the
wifiers and are uniform random perhap
beta uniform random y in the second
round and then the pro the proof will
proceeds to the third one Z to apply the
finisher here uh using this correlation
travel hash we're going to
so the idea is we are going to replace
the second message y with the hash of
the first message X
to prove the security of this financial
paradigm
the idea is to firstly Define a water is
a bad bad challenge why
so we say the second message Y is bad if
with respect to the first message with
respect to our fixed the first message X
if it gives the approver a chance to
achieve
so this is a just an intuitive
description and the more precisely it
means that we need to define a better
relation
and this relation contains all the pairs
of alpha sorry all the pairs of X and Y
such that there exists a certain message
that can make the protocol transcript
start with X and Y
be accepted by the Wi-Fi
for any Force for any fixed uh Force
statement
so once we have this better relation we
can then use the correlation
intractability of this hash function to
argue the security of financial mirror
so so in this work we care about a
particular relation and the this
relation is called the wire available
product relation
so this relation is motivated by the
Apollo reputation
the protocols so suppose we want to
apply Financial mirror to
suppose we want to apply for the Shamir
to color reputation of some interactive
protocol for example here is a parallel
repetition of a three-round interactive
protocol so here we have a T public
repetitions
and we can denote the collection of all
the first message as X
and note that if we consider the bad
relation of this parallel repetition
then it has it satisfies our additional
structure because intuitively
for any fixed X if the concatenation of
y1 and YT allows the approver has the
chance to cheat then this means that so
in order to have the proverb to cheat
for this interact for this part of
repetition the proofer need to be
succeed at each of the parallel
reputation
so
for any fixed X if we denote the FedEx
as the collection of other second
message that allows the approver to
cheat
then this beta X has a product structure
so this FedEx can be represented as the
set product of a battle by the one to
better T well each better I is well each
Bandai is the uh by the relation for the
iOS power repetition of this uh
interactive protocol
and uh so this is a wi-fiable products
relation just to further further require
for each of the better relation this bad
eye there exists a circuit CI such that
this bad eye is just the interrelation
defined by this CI
foreign
[Music]
relations is just a verifiable product
relation where this circular CI is a
polynomial side circuit
so under this is very useful because
without a loss of generality for any MP
release almost for any ampere relation
you can always do some partial
reputation
so and indeed this is how we achieve our
result in one of my one of our previous
work
um with a tropical engine yes
rejected
and and here it is a r so to show this
well the idea is suppose there is no
exception proof then this exactly
improved must satisfy the the condition
that this beta equals to the harsh over
and this will uh and this will
contradict this correlation
interactivity
for this value relation because
all right so say I need to be opening
normal size circuit it will be
efficiently computable uh so in in their
work they handle any efficiently
computable
yes yes uh yeah in fact uh in fact you
also need to be as far as
so the formal condition is a
uh so you can think
um so so the efficiency of such a hash
function is almost the same as the
public reputation of the interactive
protocol
resulted in this uh so it's almost the
same as the
uh in the information as an article
setting in the interactive settings
so for any interactive protocol you can
do parallel application to amplify
soundness
and the amount of interaction in the
amount of power application you need
using this uh hash function is almost
the same as the original uh you know
it's almost the same as the number of
parallel reputation you need in the
original Interactive
why doesn't
intractable hash for average
relation
ship so you need to because you cannot
achieve you cannot prove soundness uh
for in the interactive setting if you if
you're someone that's arrow is two is
too bad I understand that there is
a replication specify
foreign
[Music]
yeah if you're not a single color
and
she needs to be sufficient at large
because a single column doesn't have
large enough uh carotenuse
[Music]
some conditions the eye for which you
can build yeah so I mean it's easier
with trying to apply This Ti in order to
do future mutual and interactive what
we're saying here is take the
interactive proof
repetition
do an extra step of the specific is
as long as the the challenge
the challenge space in one repetition is
not super large right I mean that's why
collapsing it to T is equal to one case
will not captured uh
[Music]
zero knowledge right there are two
possible challenges
only yeah yeah so for one column it's
nothing right like you can't get sound
it's just like there are two they're
just two possible challenges one of them
is good one is bad yes
reputation for sure you need it is I'm
asking that
relation
[Music]
this is a special kind of relation right
and uh
what's that the specialty
if I have no conditional CI at all
we efficiently verified they efficiently
verifiable makes it hard to extend this
to General because you should be able to
efficiently test if the challenges but
so the scarcity like if the number of
bad challenges divided by the size of
the talent space will determine how many
times you need to parallel repeat them I
see only that part is different okay
it doesn't give you CI for General
relations but you can do future means
so let's continue so so this will handle
many uh
so essentially it can almost handle all
uh MP relations uh because for any
interrelation you can also you can
always do this power reputation
so and this is indeed how we achieve our
results in our previous work joined with
a concrete energy so in other words we
first building this interactive protocol
for bachelor MP and then we apply the
financial mirror using such a say a
harsh from the work by home Gran at all
then we compiled to builders not for
patiently
but in this work since our focus is you
build snark-strong DP home assumption so
we cannot use this latest assumption
anymore so can we do this say hash for
product to wifiable products relations
from DP hormone assumption
so suppose we can achieve this then we
can start with some interactive protocol
for passion P from DP hormone assumption
then we apply this uh say hash for
whatever product relation from Deep home
assumption and then we can build snarks
for batch MP from TBH
so that's the high level overview
so and here is our intermediate result
so in this work we contracted this
correlation intractable hash for tc0
wi-fiable product relation
or sub-exponential ddh
and in our construction for any input
lens and the running time of our hash
function is a slightly super polynomial
image so the running time is into the
order of order
so we can think to make this a running
time a polynomial we need to restrict
the input length to some small sample
polynomial in lamina in this way we can
obtain our polynomial running time
so in the rest of this talk I'm going to
show you how to build this uh
relation trackable hash for t60 wifiable
product relations from sub-exponential
dth
oh pc0
so yeah I will show you yeah maybe I
will explain later
so
um but before that so let me first show
you some background about Sarah hash so
uh let me first show you how to build
the cell hearts for searchable relations
so what is searchable relation so we say
our relation R is searchable if there is
exists artificial function f such that
this R is a completely characterized by
this function f f so this is a relation
R well just to contain the input Auto
output pairs of this function I have for
any input X
and here I'm going to show you a very
simple construction of Crash for
searchable relations from a circular
secure
photographic encryption
so so let's uh apigee B is on a circular
secure photographic encryption scheme
so the hatch function we construct has
the following hashiki so the hashiki
just consists of the fully homework
encryption of the this of the
description of this function f
and we said to use a Cyber attack style
for hash key
so to compute a hash the idea is to take
a for any input X we are going to form
only we are going to
homographically evaluate uh the
universal circuit with X Hardwell in it
and in this way we can compute our cyber
text which contains the which is a
separate text of f of x
the next um
by assuming circular secure fhg we can
promotically decrypt this separate text
so we can obtain our fhe encryption of
the decryption of FX
another hash value is set as the
leveraging encryption of the decryption
of f of x plus and shift so let's say we
pass some Vector once
and this is the hash value so this is
the contraction in the work by Kennedy
at all
and the next I'm going to show you why
this construction is correlation
intractable for this uh function
s
so you what is there
so decryption algorithm has the security
Hardware so you so we are so so the
construction also assume a circular
so it internally decrypted this it
treats this f of x as some server text
and decrypted
so decryption of f x you just mean f x
there
it's the decryption of fat
it's just f x
uh so so it's uh so
effective I mean encryption of it
[Music]
okay so the decryption of the encryption
encryption step first then he does a
good thing
so if you see oh next for some reason
yes
uh yeah so you decrease the f of x under
the um
okay right
yeah so you said just to show the uh
so I will show you this construction so
the construction look like this I know I
will show you the satisfies correlation
capability so suppose I was very
confined designs such as the pairs under
this satisfies the situation then this
means that since this relation is
researchable this means that this hash
of x equals to f of x
and if we take a picking the
construction of this hush function then
this means this apigee encryption of the
decryption of f of x plus this shift
equals to f of x
so if you apply the decryption on both
sides then you you obtain this
decryption of f of x plus this shift
equals to the decryption of f of x and
you can cancel this decryption on both
sides then you will reach a
contradiction
so now we show that if suppose some
other words where you can find some
input X you can break the correlation
interactivity then we can find some
contradiction in this way we prove the
correlation interactivity
so this is how the work by connectors
contracts this uh very hard for
searchable relations
and later in the beautiful work by yeah
so and the laser is quite a beautiful
word or for Piper They constructed the
associated from for searchable relations
foreign
learning with arrow assumptions
and but in this work our focus is on the
DP Homer solution so can we build this
share hash from TV home assumption
from typical summation previously we
only know how to build the serial hash
from approximate constant degree
polynomial from different assumption and
this is by the work of proxy at all
and the main challenge here towards
building Serge from ddh for generals for
more General circuit is that
the DP Homer summation is defined in a
cyclic group
so in a cyclic group it assumes that the
only homophone we can do is the linear
Automotive
question
so so that paper you also need LPM but
the two people with this uh
so the main challenge is that in the
certification is defined in a second
group and in a secondary group we only
know how to do linear formalism it seems
that don't know any of them
so and this is very different from that
it is awesome because of based on this
we can feel the body homework encryption
and that you overcome this uh barrier so
one of the reason I want to joining is
uh change we contracted a hash for uh
searchable relations from
sub-exponential dth
another key idea is here is to use more
interaction to emulate this foreign
so we first relax this hash function so
here is our review of our construction
so we first relax this hash function to
some interactive passion protocol where
we allow the harsh algorithm and the key
generation algorithm to interact in
multiple run in back and force
and as you can imagine in any two rounds
of this interactive protocol we can
compute some linear function
and then we compose these linear
functions sequentially two percent a
more complicated function
and then we use a round collapsing
technique to compress this interactive
hashing protocol to obtain a hash
function without any interaction so here
uh we we stop at the tc0 because in this
wrong compression Technique we need to
use some complexity leverage and uh if
we use too many complexity leveraging
you know we cannot use we cannot realize
on some exponential hardness of TDH
if you want to know more details we can
discuss
but in this work
um our goal is to be able to say a harsh
for verifiable product relations
and uh so let me firstly record what is
wi-fiable product relation
so so for such a relation for any given
input X
the Battle of X can be decomposed as the
product of several sets
and our first observation is that if
each battery I only contains one element
under the challenge space for each uh
bad eye is a polynomial then indeed I
can enumerate every y in the challenge
space and the check whether it is bad
and if it is bad I just output it so in
this way I can build a series of
functions from F1 into ft where each
function will output the unique bed
elements in this bad eye
no I can
now this is a wi-fiable product relation
is essentially a searchable relation
because I can just concatenate this F1
to Ft together to obtain a function to
obtain efficient function
so here we crucially realize on two
points so one one is this uh each part I
only contains one element and the second
is the size of this challenge space is
polynomial
so
uh how about the body challenge how
about multiple better challenges
so for any uh relation R sorry so yeah
can you go back yeah so I understand
it's searchable
um and am I supposed to be happy now or
I don't understand the connection to tc1
or anything
uh yes a good question so in fact we
also
um so to make this uh to make this
searchable uh in in fact to apply our uh
say hash for tc0 searchable relation we
also require this F1 to ft to be in tc0
but uh and to make uh to make that
possible we need to
make the verification circuit for each
bad eye to be a txl circuit
this enumeration process is also
interested because you can enumerate all
possible way in parallel
good question
so
um right so
and uh so how do we handle these
multiple better challenges so for any
relation r
our idea is to divide the challenges
based uh why
as a several components from where I
want to ID so you can imagine if this uh
Y is 0 1 to M let's say so if Y is the
strings of a length M then each y i is a
final string of lens so each wire
contains all the binary strings of
length M divided by D
in this way we can divide this challenge
space evenly to several small challenge
space
and the idea is that uh by this device
dividing process maybe we can also
divide the better challenges
among these what I want to ID so that
they could be unique
so let's take another view of this
dividing process
yep
okay
uh
so
so initially we have challenge space y
and
so and then next I'm going to send I'm
going to compute each element in the
component of Y in this y12yd so in the
first step I'm going to compute the Y
one and the next I'm going to compute
the Y the component of Y in Y2 so on and
so forth so that's the first Focus about
focus on the first step
so
uh computer is component anywhere one is
essentially dividing the whole challenge
space into the size of capital y1
subsets
and then uh value in y1 a value in this
component of capital y1 essentially is a
index for this subset so right when
we'll choose one subset
under under the computation of the
component of Y in Y2 is essentially
dividing this subset further to Capital
y two parts
and then we take one uh parts from from
them and this part is the indexed by Y2
and so on and so forth
so and the hope is that in this dividing
process we hope the
better better challenges were spread
among different subsets
so that and here our key observation is
that
at most one subset will contain more
than half of the bad challenges
and this way we can obtain uniqueness so
essentially now we can reduce any better
relation to the unique better better
challenge case and apply our produced
Construction
so that's the initial idea
so Suppose there were two bad challenges
in each of the
sets from the for each of the parallel
repetitions yes what happens
so so overall there's two to the two bad
challenges that's too many
so you mean there are two better
challenges in total no there are two for
each you're doing T repetitions and then
each of the repetitions are two possible
bad challenges so two to the T in total
that challenges so what happens here so
here I'm going to divide the whole
challenges based on
I'm going to firstly divide the whole
Chinese space to Capital One subsets and
uh I'm going to select one of the subset
and I continue to divide it and the
continue to divide it to y1 Y2 supersize
and I'm going to choose
this slide is not for the product
setting yet this is even just
considering the setting that
in a relation right non-product relation
with the let's say some number of bad
challenges and some challenge space if
you could handle searchable relations
now can you how can you go to multiple
bad challenges so just for the single
repetition setting he's first describing
an idea which then extends to the
parallel case so there'll be only two
dots in this setting for your example
and you argue that there's only one of
these slices which will have more than
one dollar
at most
so let's say three dots
you can be at most one slice we still
have two thoughts okay one quick
question
is there a niceness relationship like is
it a uh
so we don't need to have any structures
we just divide them in any anyway
so key observation is that by using this
dividing process each time when we
divide this challenge space there are at
most one subset that contains more than
half of the number of better challenges
so in this way you can obtain uniqueness
so
uh so
so next I'm going to show you how to use
this idea to build a hash function
so all I do is to divide the Chinese
space to this y12 yd
and now I'm going to firstly recall how
this
is which is not the majority subset if
they take and therefore you end up with
only one dot is that
so the argument is that so Suppose there
are two subsets that contains more than
half of the number of bad challenges
then in total the number of running
challenges is more than one fraction
I get this but so what if you choose the
one subset which has more than half of
the virtualities
oh good question so you you are
seriously
so uh
so so our construction so we will
Contracting yourself as follows so let's
firstly recall how Sarah hash is used in
uh in the financial Paradigm so let's
say we have some text protocol where the
Proverbs under the personal message of X
and then the Wi-Fi sends a random
challenge y
so now instead of sending this right
directory we are going to replace it
with some interactive protocol where the
Wi-Fi first assigned the first component
for example are component in y1 and the
second example a second component of Y2
so on and so forth and then finally we
concatenate all of those channels
together to obtain the challenge device
maybe there is a no difference between
this and the original interactive
protocol by detracty standard is a
challenge y
so the difference is that if we apply
the financial mirror to this interactive
protocol then we obtain this uh
iterative construction of crash so
to apply attention to it we are going to
first compute the y1 as the hash of X
and this is some hash function H1 and
then we compute the H2 we compute the Y2
as the hash of X and the Y what and so
on and so forth so at any step where I
used to complete a harsh for x and the Y
one two y i minus one
so and our goal is to show that for
for each year
Oracle is to show that we are going to
Define our unique better challenge for
each y i then we can use a educate we
can instantiate this harsh function Hy
as the say H4 unique battery challenge
then we can argue the correlation
interact ability of this construction uh
so so for your question so the idea is
uh we can we can catch that case we can
catch that case when when you really
choose the uh where I when you choose a
real choose a better A Better Way by
using the correct correlation
interactivity of sound hi
this Construction
yeah uh so I I think I round off a run
out of the time and this is the so so
this is the a high level idea of the
construction there are many challenge
but there are many challenges in this uh
in this work for example uh
yeah
so
where's um
so for TP hormone we don't have all this
of movies
such as suppose we only know how to use
I know that's a respective to
contractors
so the previous construction of this
homegrown at all they need to realize on
this recoverable this is a recoverable
code so that construction we need to use
cell hash for searchable relationships
it's called the Mr recoverable code
for some come up with the district
recoverable codes with decoding in tc0
that would be helpful yes
yes
uh yeah I think so I think it also
applies
[Applause]
nice enough to take some more questions